[Music]
ursula kayla green puts in the mouths of
her mages in a wizard of earthy a very
important term
that winds up being a key concept not
just for them
but i think you could say running
throughout the entire work and
the rest of the earth see novels and
stories as well and this word is
equilibrium
now
many people view this as liguine
importing the taoism
that she was very influenced by
admittedly so
into earthsea and you know if we look at
how it's explained and how it plays
itself out that's you know we don't want
to say it's exactly the same thing but
there is this sense that there is a
balancing an equilibrium if we use that
term
means that their things are balanced
against each other they come to
a sort of
stasis between them but it could also be
dynamic
and sometimes it gets out of whack and
then has to be
restored and there's all sorts of
modalities to equilibrium running
throughout earthsea
it comes up in the context of magic
named first
as such
in these books particularly
in the chapter in which get is getting
his his education
uh before
his tragic disruption
of the equilibrium that we'll talk about
in a moment and there's lessons that are
coming
page after page after page from three of
the main masters at roke one of them is
master hand the other is the master
namer and then the master
summoner and we could say that with each
of these we're getting a sort of
deepening of the teaching about the
equilibrium so
master hand is asked about
how to make things no longer just seem
to be changed but to really change them
for example to change a pebble into a
diamond and so he says that
we we use the true speech or you know
the old speech to
control things that's what magic largely
consists in and he says that
this is a rock a bit of the stone of
which roque isle is made a bit of the
dry land on which people live it is
itself it's part of the world by
illusion change you can make it look
like a diamond
but to change something into something
else you have to change its true name
and this he says is quite dangerous why
because this is to change the world
he says it is the art of the master
changer you're going to
do you're going to learn it when you're
ready to learn it but you must not
change
one thing one pebble one grain of sand
until you know what good and evil will
follow on that act and then here's where
he he talks about equilibrium the world
is in balance in equilibrium
a wizard's power of changing and of
summoning can shake the balance of the
world it is dangerous that power it is
most perilous it must follow knowledge
and serve need to light a candle
is to cast a shadow now notice what he
said there it's not just well everything
is in balance you know it's every uh
season etc etc he's saying listen
you have to maintain the equilibrium by
thinking about good and thinking about
evil these are not concepts that we just
relativize or say well we go beyond them
because that would actually be evil
there's a goodness in maintaining the
equilibrium in certain ways but
sometimes the equilibrium might need to
be
shifted there's evil involved in
disrupting the equilibrium but not all
evil is exactly the same
and there you know might be some harsh
remedies he points out something very
prosaic a rock is a good thing too you
know if the isles adversity were made of
diamond we'd lead a hard life
right so that is the first discussion
about equilibrium
shortly after that in the story but much
later many months later
we find that
the
equilibrium
is something
that has to be taken into account not
just in terms of good and evil
and
thinking about what you're trying to do
but consequences and we get an
environmental
approach to it an ecological approach
what what do we mean by that
well the the master namer tells ged this
he's talking about the name of the c
since no thing can have two names indian
can mean
only all the sea except the enmo c and
of course it does not mean even that for
their seas and bays and straits beyond
county that bear names if some
mage sea master were mad enough
to try to lay a spell of storm or calm
over all the ocean
his spell must say not only that word
but the name of every stretch and bit of
the part of the sea through the
archipelago and all the outer reaches
and beyond to our names cease
thus that which gives us the power to
work magic sets the limits of that power
a mage can control only what is near him
what he can name exactly and holy and
this is well this is the key point
if it were not so
the wickedness of the powerful or the
folly of the wise would long ago have
sought to change what cannot be changed
and equilibrium
would fail the unbalanced sea would
overwhelm the islands where we
perilously dwell and in the old silence
all voices and all names
would be lost so this is a very
important
lesson that he's being taught here it's
not just that well you know before you
cast a spell think about what you're
doing
it's also if you're going to
you know
change things in a global sense you
might actually screw up the whole world
and thank goodness that that's too
complicated of a task for anybody to
really
pull off
then we get another
lesson as well
we find out
from
the master summoner
that
equilibrium plays an important role
there too
he tells us
that here we go
ged worked with the master summoner now
but that master was a stern man aged and
hardened by the deep and somber wizardry
he taught he dealt with no illusion only
true magic the summoning of such
energies as light and heat and the force
that draws the magnet and those forces
men perceive as weight form color sound
real powers drawn from the immense
fathomless energies of the universe
which no man's spells or uses could
exhaust or unbalance
the weather workers and sea masters
calling upon wind and water were already
known to his pupils but
he it was he this is the master summoner
who showed why the true wizard uses such
spells only at need
since to summon up such earthly forces
is to change the earth of which they are
apart and now we get again an ecological
approach
rain on rock maybe drought and osskill
he said and a column in the east reach
may be storm and ruin in the west unless
you know what you are about
you're not supposed to be carrying on
wizardry without attending to
the very complex
dynamic equilibrium of the environment
around you because you could produce all
sorts of other problems and we do in
fact see this
happening in some of the later
works not so much with
weather but with
other things so that's one set of very
important explanations we also see ged
himself explaining this to his friend
vetch's sister
um yarrow
as she is preparing food for them and
she says listen why don't you wizards
just like say a word and you know make
yourself some nice meat pies while
you're out there sailing around and god
says well you can eat your words but
they're not very
satisfying meat pie is only a word we
can make it odorous and savorous even
filling but it remains a word it fools
the stomach and gives no strength to the
hungry man and yarrow says oh well you
know it's a good thing i'm making you
something but i still don't understand
sparrowhawk i've seen my brother even
his apprentice make light in a dark
place only by saying one word but the
light shines
it's bright it's not a word but a light
you can see your way by and god says yes
light is a power by which we exist but
exists beyond our needs in itself
sunlight and starlight are time and time
is light and he goes on and he says to
summon a thing
that is not there at all to call it by
speaking its true name that is a great
mastery not lightly used not for mere
hunger's sake euro your little dragon
has stolen a cake and then she says so
you would not summon up a real meat pie
unless you disturb what my brother is
always talking about i forget its name
equilibrium gad said soberly for she was
serious
and he goes on a little bit and they
talk about equilibrium in kind of a
joking way uh he steals a cake and she
says you have burned fingers then and
when you're starving on the waste water
between the far aisles you'll think of
that cake and say ah had i not stolen
that cake i might eat it now alas i
shall eat my brothers so he can starve
with you and then god jokingly says thus
is equilibrium
maintained and then they they joke
around about that so equilibrium you
know affects it
derives produces the consequences
of what it is that we take and give and
produce and
think about now there's also another
important lesson about the equilibrium
without naming it very early on and this
is when ged
first brings the
shadow of the shadow the thing
stooping by the doorway
into
the world
so
ogian
actually
tells him this
have you never thought how danger must
surround power as shadow does light
this sorcery is not a game we play for
pleasure or praise think of this this is
the lesson about the equilibrium
every word every act of our art is said
and is done either for good
or for evil
before you speak or do
you must know the price
that is to pay
this is about the equilibrium and get
acts without thinking about the price
early on this is something that he has
to to learn there's another important
lesson that ojn also conveys and it has
to do with his own experience as well
here we go uh this is after get is
turned into the falcon and came to ogeon
is able to be transformed back as a boy
ojin like all boys had thought it would
be a very pleasant game to take by art
magic whatever shape one wanted man or
beast tree or cloud and so to play at a
thousand beings but as a wizard he had
learned the price of the game which is
the peril
of losing oneself playing away the truth
the longer a man stays in a form not his
own the greater this peril
every apprentice sorcerer learns the
tale of the wizard board gir of way who
delighted in taking bears shape and did
more did so more and more often until
the bear grew in him and the man died
away and he became a bear and killed his
own little son in the forest and was
hunted down and slain and no one knows
how many of the dolphins that leap in
the waters of the inmocia were men once
wise men who forgot their wisdom and the
name and the joy of the restless sea
transforming oneself
is a changing of the equilibrium and
things can shift back in such a way that
you can be caught in the form that
you've taken on now
you can look at the story of a wizard of
earth see
where get as the main character
as a overall art you know overarching
depiction of ged upsetting
and then restoring the equilibrium
partly within the world but also partly
within himself
so first there is the shadow of the
shadow he's taunted by this this uh
daughter of a witch who is is uh half a
witch herself
and will actually show up later on in
the work as sarah
to read a spell from ogian's books and
he reads the wrong spell through
you know the witch's doing
and brings into being a shadow being
something that is
terrifying and ogen drives it away and
later there's discussion was that the
shadow itself no it's just merely the
shadow of a shadow
then we have bringing the shadow itself
into the world and this is a damaging of
the equilibrium
in multiple respects get is not supposed
to be doing this kind of magic he's also
bringing into the world something that
is is quite terrible
and
um
it causes the death of the arch mage so
there's a lot of
awful things going on we we have a tear
in the word in the world torn edges
to it and uh you know there's a
discussion later on about what exactly
happened and this happens in the context
of the new ark mage
asking ged uh what he what he wants to
do
what do you want god says to stay to
learn to undo the evil
nemerley himself could not do that no i
would not let you go from
rock because this creature could possess
you and you would be a puppet doing the
will of the evil
shadow that you raised into
the sunlight and he gives a
sort of explanation of it
he
says
it has no name you have great power
inborn in you and you use that power
wrongly there's a key term
to work a spell over which you had no
control not knowing how that spell
affects the balance
of light and dark life and death good
and evil you reduce your move to do so
by pride and hate is it any wonder the
result was ruined you summoned a spirit
from the dead
but with it came one of the powers of
unlife uncalled it came from a place
where there are no names evil it wills
to work evil through you the power you
had to give it
call it gives it power over you you are
connected
it is the shadow of your arrogance the
shadow of your ignorance the shadow you
cast has a shadow a name so
the arc mage is saying listen body you
really disrupted the equilibrium in a
whole bunch of different ways here and
get wants to fix it he's trying to
undo the damage there's a very
interesting
discussion that comes up as well a
little bit later
where the pteranodon this this stone
that is one of the old powers
they're trying to get him to
use it when it will really be using
him
and this is sarat talking to him she
says
only shadow can fight shadow only
darkness can defeat the dark
listen sparrowhawk what do you need then
to defeat the shadow who waits for you
outside these walls i need what i cannot
know its name the pteranodon that knows
all births and deaths and beings before
and after death the unborn and the dying
the bright world and the dark one will
tell you that name
ged however says
it is light that defeats the dark light
as he spoke he saw plainly as if his own
words were the light that showed him how
indeed he'd been drawn here lured here
and that the stone would have possessed
him
and so he realizes this is not the way
to try to fight it i have to fight it
with light
then there's a little bit later a very
important realization on the part of ged
that
figures into the discussion after he's
turned against it
he says
all terror was gone all joy was gone it
was a chase no longer he was neither
hunted nor huntered now
when they had come to the time and place
for their last meeting they would meet
but until that time and elsewhere then
that place there would never be any rest
or peace for ged day or night on earth
or sea he knew now here's the
realization and the knowledge was hard
his task had never been to undo
what he had done
but to finish
what he had begun there's a very big
difference between
restoring what was damaged
and seeing something through to the end
and that's what he does
eventually restoring himself in such a
way that is described
here at the the end of the work
vetch had watched gad with a anxious
dread he was not sure what had happened
there in the dark land
now when he saw his friend and heard him
speak his doubt vanished and he began to
see the truth
that ged had neither lost nor won but
naming the shadow of his death with his
own name had made himself
whole
a man who knowing his whole true self
cannot be used or possessed by any power
other than himself and whose life is
therefore lived for life's sake and
never in the service of ruin or pain or
hatred or the dark
so this restoration
by confronting the shadow in the very
end and naming it with his own name
allows ged to restore himself and to
restore at least a portion
of the equilibrium the portion that he
himself
had disrupted so very important concept
this gives you some idea about how it
plays out at least in a wizard of
earthsea
you